merci madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
également à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
ministre nous le répétons le prix des
carburants reste bien trop peu le vîmes
épais et normé mans sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français plus encore dans le
monde rural où la voiture est
indispensable déplacements quotidiens
je le vois chez moi dans le jura nous
sommes obligés de faire souvent
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres pour
aller au travail pour emmener nos
enfants à l'école pour consulter un
médecin quand nous avons la chance d'en
trouver un pour une famille avec enfants
avec un plein de 90 e revoir deux par
semaine pour le couple on ne s'en sort
pas les conditions vous proposer pour le
futur chez carburant inquiète déjà tous
nos territoires celles et ceux qui
travaillent dur et qui font l'effort de
se lever tous les matins vont une
nouvelle fois être exclues de ce
dispositif
nous nous voulons soutenir la france qui
travaille c'est pourquoi les députés et
l'air sont force de proposition
lorsqu'il s'agit de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat par le mérite et ne pas
pénaliser ceux qui n'ont pas de moyen de
substitution à la voiture
revenons un tarif raisonnable des
carburants
nous faisons des propositions pour
financer ces mesures
notamment par des économies importantes
dans le fonctionnement bien trop lourd
de nos administrations monsieur le
ministre
cette baisse des prix du carburant ne
doit pas être réservé à seulement
quelques-uns comme vous le prévoyez dans
votre projet de loi elle doit bénéficier
à tous pour ne surtout pas oublier les
classes moyennes vous vous dit prêt à
entendre nos propositions et bien là
vous en avez l'occasion ma question est
donc simple êtes vous prêt à entendre
cette demande et à renoncer à une mesure
ciblée en brise en décembre les prix à
la pompe pour tous
[Applaudissements]